i think for me because i was an
immigrant because i had bad grades my
whole life i was losing
that by the time i was a grown-up
losing and fear didn't mean anything to
me
so i got lucky in so much adversity as a
child
i think if you haven't had that or even
if you have that you still fear it
because of the way your parents judged
you know you have to practice
you know it's you know like you have to
practice
doing things that you are scared of it's
very true it's like when people talk to
me about fear it feels so heavy i'm like
it's like swimming or kissing a boy you
were scared of that when you were young
until you did it and then you were you
were talking to me right but then
practice gets you there so you have to
practice things that feel scary and then
you'll get more used to them it's the
truth
it's just the truth
the number one thing you can do for your
confidence is to do scary things when
you come up against something that's
scary that's difficult that's hard and
you don't do them you're telling
yourself that you can't and that you
suck you're teaching yourself with every
inaction that you're the kind of person
who plays small
you need to flip that thinking it's
scary you do it it's scary you're
jumping because you do scary things so i
was talking to alex this morning on my
team alex helps me run toronto dance
salsa canada's largest salsa dancing
business maybe north america's we need
to figure out that number actually
somehow businesses are private it's hard
to figure it out but anyway i'm talking
alex this morning and he as part of his
daily challenge is doing
omegle video so omegle if you don't know
megal is a platformer you can chat with
strangers and and his goal is to connect
with people around the world and get
better at coaching motivating inspiring
helping them feel his who which is
belong and so he does this every morning
you press a button and you just get
paired via video with some random
stranger based off of certain interests
and so he had some guy on today and he
said evan you need to hire this guy for
your business he was so great he's got
such a big heart his one word is love is
who is love we need you need to hire him
i said well you why don't you hire him
why don't you bring him into tbs why
don't you
why don't you recruit him
and he said you're right and i need to i
need to not be scared and he's putting
this pressure on himself to not be
scared and said no it's not that you
need to not be scared
if you're not scared it's because you're
living a life so small that you're just
photocopying the same day over and over
and over again
you want to be scared if you have things
that make you scared it means you're
growing you're learning you're getting
better if there's nothing in your
calendar that makes you scared in the
next month you hate your life
that's actually most people most people
don't have anything in their calendar
that is scary and they look at their
calendar ahead and they hate their life
they're bored
they're photocopying the same day over
and over again you don't want that
so the goal isn't to not be scared
because that means you're playing small
the goal is to find things that are
scary and then to teach yourself that
you do them and so he reached out it's
okay you're right i'm going to reach out
so he reached out to them and we'll see
that was just today see what happens uh
we had another example where the
security guard in my building here
uh is just one of the most loving warm
people that you're ever going to meet
i've i've seen a lot of security guards
i guess over the years of of being in
hotels living in hotels and being here
and there aren't that many people who
are as friendly as she is you walk in
and she's warm and she's kind and she's
waving hello and she's asking how you
are and even if you've never met her
before she's still giving you
basically a hug from afar and i told
alex you need to recruit this person
uh you need to you need to come over
here and you need to recruit this person
and so he eventually drove over here
over to my place and he he was scared he
took him a half an hour or so before
driving because he wasn't sure what he
was gonna say like how do you
how do you come over and say hey i want
i want you to join my salsa dance school
i think you'd be a good instructor super
random and creepy right
so eventually he did it and and he had a
conversation and alex used to be a
security guard and she's a security
guard and he wanted to be a cop and she
apparently wants to be a cop and anyway
they got to talk and he he said hey i
want to teach you how to be an
instructor are you interested to have
the impact that you want to have and she
said yes and they just started their
training but again it's a case of doing
scary things that's not typically how we
would recruit an instructor but when you
find an opportunity
and you get this idea especially for
entrepreneurs you get this idea in your
head that you want to do it
the fact that you want to do it and it's
different it means that it's going to be
scary your big dreams your big goals the
impact that you want to have is all on
the other side of scary
and the worst thing you can do is teach
yourself that when you hit something
scary you play small because that
becomes
a pattern that then becomes hard to
break because every time you do it
you're teaching yourself i play small i
play small i'm too scared i can't do it
i play small i play small that's the
record that then loops you need to break
that record you need to snap that record
in half
and replace it with the i do scary
things because everything you want
everything you want in life is on the
other side of you saying yes and doing
scary things okay so how do we do scary
things how do we summon the courage that
we need to lean into the difficult
things three steps let's go step number
one is scary difficult to heart these
are the triggers that i use for myself
it's so hard to actually figure out when
you're making the mistake we're so good
at finding
really logical excuses and reasons let's
call them reasons because they're not
excuses right we're so good at finding
really logical reasons why we shouldn't
do something but really you're just
afraid you wouldn't believe a really
stupid reason
so you're gonna find a really smart
reason why you won't do it but really
you're just afraid and so trigger words
for me are scary difficult to heart if i
ever say scary difficult to heart if my
wife my son my friends the people around
me my team ever hear me say right
they can't hear me think but when i
think it scary difficult or hard they
call me out i try to calm myself out too
to say now i have to do it
because scary difficult to heart are no
longer good enough reasons again as long
as it's not going against your core
values you're not hurting somebody
you're not doing something stupid right
most of the things that are scary
difficult hard for you are really just
at the end of the day somebody else's
opinion
you're not worried about failing you're
worried about failing in front of
somebody else and that is not a good
enough reason for you not to take action
so when you hear write or say scary
difficult or hard that means it's go
time you run in you jump towards let's
move step number two is the boom boom
boom test and that's your heart going
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom so scary difficult to heart our
uh our thoughts our language boom boom
boom test is physical when you're
feeling your heart going boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom that means
you're scared it's the same thing it's
just a physical version of it instead of
you actually vocalizing or thinking it
and so same reaction when you feel your
heart going like this when you can catch
it you may not always catch it that's
okay but when you catch it when you
catch it what do you do because when you
catch yourself feeling scared do you
again find a logical reason why you
can't do it
and force yourself to play small or do
you say ooh
i'm feeling it it's go time right again
you want to teach yourself scary
difficult to heart or your heart's going
boom boom boom boom boom go time we do
it we jump in we move forwards we demand
action and then step number three is tie
yourself forward to the effort not the
result this is another big mindset shift
that if you can make it will change your
life most people tie their self-worth to
the result to winning to getting a
certain outcome if you do that if that's
how you base your self-worth right i
only get my confidence my pride my
self-love when i get a certain result
you're only going to play small for life
because you're only going to take on the
projects where you know you're going to
get a result in so you play small for
life
where most successful people they don't
know they're going to get a result
they're trying a whole bunch of new
stuff all the time they're constantly
failing but they don't tie their
self-worth to winning they tie their
self-worth to the effort
if you tie yourself forth to the effort
most days you'll wake up and you may not
win you may not get the result you're
looking for but overall you're going to
accomplish way more things
way more things than the person who ties
their self-worth only to winning so
learn practice pat yourself on the back
for when you tried your hardest you
tried your hardest to make your first
youtube video it sucked
who cares about the results nobody liked
it it only had one comment and it says
you suck great
you pat yourself on the backside i did
my best i did my best i'm gonna wake up
and tomorrow i'm gonna do it again if
you did that every day your life will
change the impact that you want to make
will come true you'll be able to build
the actual business and life that you
deserve that your family deserves that
the people around you deserve
can you tell i'm excited about this guys
you have to learn to tie your self-worth
to your effort and not the results that
you're getting also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
the way i do branding
i sell so infrequently uh that i think
some of you that are watching me the
hardest core
need to hear this which is it's okay to
sell especially if you believe in
something like if you believe in what
you're selling and that's what i'm
spending a lot of time on now trying to
spend more time
on really getting to a place where i
really believe in stuff instead i was
just passive not creating so i wasn't
selling because i didn't believe you
know and just letting everything come to
me
but as i create these you know events
vayner experience a lot of events very
big on events events are so valuable
just watching the 4ds crew it's value
and like how it's impacting their
business for ten thousand dollars right
there i mean you see i know you're
getting emails
um
the wine club like 150 worth of wine for
55 bucks like i've just locked into
members it's going to make all your
thanksgivings ridiculous
the conference 500
2 hour session in my stomping grounds
good deal compared to like other
conferences that i speak at
um but you're getting the wine for free
or you're getting the talk for free and
you're getting the wine so like
i'm very fascinated because i'm putting
more pressure on myself to create things
that i really believe in
which then allows me to sell more and i
just think for a lot of you
selling the ask the right hook is very
difficult
uh your your passive you like the idea
of like feeling good about like giving
out content this and that when you
believe in something
you can sell it and and you should put
more pressure on yourself to
create things that you believe in
biggest problem is so many of you sell
you don't believe in you're just doing
it for the money you're gonna lose
that i don't like
i think when i get the praise
it's what does that have to do with me
when i get on i'm like that's on me and
i'll fix it and i think those you know
that was i said it really quick
but it's accountability
it's accountability
and ownership when you suck and it's
passing on the credit
when you
rule
and that's it
and that's me and that's my makeup
and that's why i'm winning in life and
that's why i'm always going to win
because when you're 100 accountable
and you know you're
you're garbage when you're 100
accountable when there's an issue
and when you pass on the praise when
you're getting it
you become fundamentally undefeated
unbeatable i'm straight up unbeatable
because my head will never get gassed up
enough
ever when i'm getting it good
and uh
and i'll never believe it's me and when
it's bad i'll never point the
finger to anybody else all your finger
pointers
pointing everywhere everybody's pointing
fingers pointing them everywhere it's
everybody's pumping yourself your
country your environment your parents
school system your boss
and
circumstance and of course and of course
there's tragedies
and crimes and
child abuse and real bad stuff i'm not
saying it's not real i'm saying for the
95 of you
it's a mindset thing
perspective
perspective is everything
grounded in my perspective
never too high never too low
it's about them when it's good it's
about me when it's bad that's me
that's what i got for you that's where
i'm at that's my mindset
and i never waver
100
never
had my bad days
myself
let me just talk to you guys about why
toys r us filing chapter 11 matters toys
r us
did two things over the last couple
decades that make no sense one very
early in the 2000s they outsourced
themselves to amazon they didn't believe
in the internet
17 years ago so let amazon do their
fulfillment which started people getting
used to buying toys on the internet
through an amazon world but most
importantly they just didn't innovate
you know and when you don't innovate you
die like you could have made
toys toys r us three years ago could
have created the national
lego championships and everybody would
be there there was a million they could
have made slime centers they could have
they could be killing it right now with
their locations but no they choose to
just like sell toys out of it and none
of you want to go there first of all
you're going to go to walmart and pick
it up for less money anyway while you
pick up your groceries anything else and
if you even want to leave your home and
you don't and so you'll go to amazon and
do it that way or buy it from somebody's
youtube channel link or
you know instagram account it's just
it's it's the best example right now of
like how in trouble everybody is if they
rest on their laurels you know if toys r
us the dominant niche retail leader of a
humongous multi-billion dollar category
is finished
what do you think is going to happen
over the next six years today's rough
babin here is uh all bent out of shape
he just said uh today is rough to be
very frank with you vaynernation i don't
give a
if tyler or you think today was rough
because i had 17 meetings that he
couldn't be a part of because i'm
actually running a business here i'm not
from some teenage beanie bopper trying
to do a vlog or some influence or doing
a vlog or some family that's hoping for
some free detergent because of their
blog i'm working here tyler so sorry
that your
video blog is rough
but let me tell you what's not rough
what's not rough is we're living through
the great era of ground shift in
marketing and business everybody in this
amazing town of new york city which is
let me just tell you everybody who's not
here vibrant at 10 p.m right now because
98 of your cities are sleeping
everybody here is
a collective pants because the ground is
shifting everything that our
grandparents and parents grew up with
everything that we knew tried and true
the stable
pillars of media commerce
uh influence persuasion the way we make
decisions the things we buy and how what
is cool and what is not is on
call
the world is on call
and you know what that means hustlers
the opportunity is obnoxious so whether
you're focusing on vlogs
or influencers
or how to hack instagram stories or how
to create alexa voice skills
or how to create your own podcast
because you see i'm
full
committed till if you are not following
my podcast
pissed
the way i call today the the sum up
of all my meetings today none of which
you just watched
is that the earth is moving
there's instability in the foundation of
how it was which makes an innovator like
me really happy and what suffocates all
you b players because you like it you
like it nice slow and stable let it be
very clear with this ending rant that
game is over and the people that are
gonna win over the next five to seven
years are gonna be very comfortable in
controlled
chaos so you better get your speed up
you better work harder you better work
smarter you better try things you better
keep your subjectiveness and your ego at
the door because that slows you down and
it doesn't make you do you better
move two things i want to do i want
everybody to get out their cell phone
because we are trying to all of our
social media presence here
and wherever you are
so go get out your phone and follow joey
on instagram and like the
facebook page for prn roofing my
question bro hold on
did you really think that was a good
idea
[Applause]
no bro i honestly think that that was
one of like the worst moves i've ever
seen because
and i and i'm not trying to razz you i
appreciate i'm trying to give you love i
love the passion to win the problem is
you tried to close on the first move
you brought them no value and you asked
them to bring you value
like you gave like i will stand up here
and give a load of value and never
mention one time for any of them to
follow me and a lot more of them will
follow me then they're going to follow
that bull move that you just did
[Applause]
i get it i get it but this was back to
the question that just happened this is
why i want you to win that move is
always going to lose you can't go
tonight when you go out in vegas and you
see a pretty girl at the bar you can't
go up to her and the opening move is
like here's my key let's go
but but that's what you just did let him
hold it but that's what you just did to
this audience with business because this
is an industry where it's kind of like
doggy.world so
why why are you succeeding
and giving all your secrets away at the
same time
i mean because doing the right thing is
the right thing
karma is practical
you know i heard somebody rant earlier
right that was like hey when i win i
don't think it's coming out of you the
guy that closed i couldn't know who was
on stage but i believe in that right
because i love the idea of 85 people
here going and listening to me winning i
didn't make anything for it but it then
becomes brand if she goes out and
listens and then two years later she's
having dinner with a friend and she's
talking about what happened to her life
that friend might be the ceo of ge you
know i'm playing with the biggest brands
in the world i'm not trying to monetize
my audience i'm trying to like just
bring the most value in the world and
let that lift all my other opportunities
so i think
i think giving away your best secrets is
the greatest strategy for two reasons
karma is practical and leads to more
business but here's the secret and it's
even funnier
99 of these people are not going to do
anything about it
[Applause]
the re somewhere about five or six years
ago i realized this fact
holy
people aren't gonna do anything with
this
so
like there's still gonna be plenty for
me and i'm gonna be the most lovable guy
ever i love this there is ridiculous
confusion in the system
i
am winning and will win at all time
levels get ready you will tell your
grandkids that you once saw me live like
i mean that
and by the way it's not because by the
way i don't by the way real quick
because i don't want claps for that i
need you to understand how i think about
that it's not because i think i'm fancy
or great
i think it's because i'm very common
simple about one simple tiny thing
underpriced attention
it's so grossly underpriced i'm asking
you let me tell you the story about mtv
when mtv came out in the early to mid
80s
how many people remember when mtv was
launched
when mtv was launched the biggest bands
in the world
the biggest bands in the world got
together for a dinner that one of their
managers told me about
and decided that they would not make
music videos
for mtv
because that was giving away music for
free
that why would we spend money to make a
video
put it on mtv
but when that's giving people the music
for free and they will not go out and
buy the record
at the same token up and coming artists
madonna
duran duran
and on and on
understood that it was where all the
attention of the youth was and it was a
gateway drug to the sale
they understood that mtv was a jab not
the right hook
facebook and instagram at this second
is the most underpriced scaled jab in
the history of marketing except for one
other moment from 2001
to 2005 google adwords was a
ridiculously underpriced jab how many
people here took advantage of google
2001 to 2005. raise your hands
so for you
you really know that's how i did it wine
library had no money but when you're
buying people who want to buy wine for 5
and 10 cents a click it works out real
fast when it's that underpriced
one company
one company during that time
acted the way i'm aspiring to act right
now as gary vaynerchuk on social media
one company from 2001 to 2005 spent
enough
to justify how underpriced it was
that company was a small book company
called amazon
amazon as you all know now is the
company of our world it will win
everything it hasn't even begun
literally the only thing that will stop
amazon is anti-trust government
involvement otherwise it will destroy
everything
it
got its fuel from google 2001 to 2005.
that occurrence
is happening right now on facebook and
instagram and we're not squeezing the
juice out of that fruit anywhere close
at least we
have picked up the fruit
people are like yo how do i build my
self-awareness how do i build my
optimism how do i change my mindset it's
the people around you if your best
friend is debbie downer you're not going
to be as optimistic as you can be if the
people that from your town that you hang
out with have no ambition you're going
absolutely nowhere if you listen to your
dad every day about how the government
sucks
you're not gonna love life you've got to
audit your inner circle podcast friends
listen to me listen very carefully to
this mashup and these thoughts because
this underlining tone of who you
surround yourself with absolutely
fundamentally changes who you are period
and the story when i hung out with
silicon valley in 2005 to 2010 i was a
different dude when i hang out in the
agency land right now i'm a different
dude when i'm like it's when i was in
college mount ida different dude like
you're a different person and i'm
telling you right now
this morning podcast or this podcast
because i know some of you listen to it
late this podcast if i can get one of
you one person listening to this to dump
one loser person in their circle and add
one whoever's that smiley happiest
person at work that you don't talk to
that much that's at the cubicle around
the way or that awesome like that you
don't how everybody has like you have a
friend but their friend like went to
college with them you don't really know
them but like the three times you see
them a year they're positive
and like they're doing things surround
yourself with those people seek out your
friend's friend who brings positive
vibes and make them part of your world
and cut out your homie from college that
thinks the world sucks watch what that
addition and subtraction does to your
life how do you balance clouds in the
dirt and which do you focus on more and
why so define to everybody how i define
clouds and dirt clouds to me is like the
why the strategy the macro
the big thinking the big picture
the operating system of like how you do
things and then the dirt is having the
humility to go to these meetings to
actually i post all my instagram photos
the doing the
the humility ego humility
strategy execution clouds and dirt the
way i balance it is they're both
important at all times i can swing back
and forth to them i can literally go
from a meeting where
like the call i had on the way out to
our first meeting here today purell was
with vaynermedia's c-suite about a
restructuring of how we handle all our
business super meta and i literally hung
up and i posted something on instagram
and wrote all the copy as we were
walking into our last meeting to me i
balanced them by doing whichever one is
needed at the time
and so i don't think about it as
balancing it i think about it as time
allocation like what should i be doing
with my time
and i think that
you know you made a joke of like we did
a shoot for a client and we debated on
the phone for 10 minutes where the
should be located
for that i think that's being in the
middle right i think uh
pandering to the way companies do things
we just had a meeting where they're like
oh that was provocative us as um as the
gallery media group holds
on all the other things we do us doing
what every other publishing does company
does is not a good idea that's the
middle that's not going to get you to
the next place and so for me
i'm just in the mindset of
you know
do either doing
humble dirty work like the reason i am
the best strategist in social media
out there i really believe this is
because i do both i both sit at the top
of a
media
company that really does it at scale for
the biggest companies in the world but
at the same token there's very few
humans that put out
140 pieces of content by hand a week and
reads the co i mean i literally just
replied to kyle in my client comments
who and i'm going to show you because i
don't think you guys believe me when i
do these grants i literally just replied
to kyle one second before babin's like
let's do this video like literally what
i was doing one second before then
was
[Music]
replying
to like literally like literally hearted
kyle's comment of i'm digging the recent
pics and quotes man right like
many many people watching here would
argue that my time at this point in my
career of reading kyle's comment and
harding it in that minute was a bad use
of my time i think the dirt
is the reason why i come up with such
good clouds being in the trenches drives
my strategy i live in reality and
practicality not in thesis or ideology
or reading headlines or reading about
people doing marketing
so i don't i don't
balance it
i just do whatever
is needed at that second mac you know
it's back to macro micro
micro speed i'm just always doing
something
right bobby like that is the big
breakthrough everybody on the team says
like there's just every second
and so the reason i can do something
every second is and i don't watch a
youtube video or stand by the wall water
cooler and talk about the rockets game
for 10 minutes is because i always value
the dirt and so in that half a second
that i had right now in the transition
of the call that i just had about a
macro vayner x strategy
right
the second transition i had before i
started doing a macro thing like the
vlog
was harding kyle's two cents on my last
instagram post clouds and dirt i know
that if i can
suffocate all of you today to take 25
percent of your take-home income this
year and pour it back into two people
who do video and written word
and put it into facebook and instagram
ads literally all of you will email me
24 months actually if you can start
right away
literally
25 percent of you are going to come to
me this time next year right here and be
like hold
i've been listening to your stuff for
seven years
your keynote was different in miami last
year at this time i listened i said i
don't need to go to ibiza three times
this year
i don't need to buy a better bmw this
year to make me feel good with the
neighbors
i don't need another pair of supremes or
yeezys i took the money and i put it
into karen the film
woman and rick the ad guy
and now my business is 2x this will 100
percent work
even if you suck
on camera
have zero charisma
are only eight days in the industry this
will work
because it is such underpriced attention
that the roi will work that if you're
a two
in skill
the ads are a 20 in the 10 point scale
and it closes the delta of you being
average if you literally literally and
i've said this for seven years if you
literally literally go interview the guy
who owns the gym in town the guy who
owns the pizza shop the woman that owns
the insurance brokerage if you literally
literally
literally just interview your local
community that you become the local
newspaper
in three minute video form on your phone
you don't even need to hire drock or
babin or iris your
phone if you literally take it selfie it
and interview the principal
of the school in your neighborhood
you will become the local celebrity
who can then transact
on whatever you're trying to sell that
group if you bring value to people if
you interview the best high school
basketball player
literally just that
your business will change or
if you literally just give the advice of
how you got here
what you learned if you shared your
thoughts
if you do not understand that you were a
media company
then you will not be as successful as
you are today in a decade
and that's not interesting when the
alternative is you're four to seven
times bigger the state guys you have to
understand what happened to blockbuster
and netflix what happened with uber and
taxi companies what happened with hotels
versus airbnb
is happening with you as a human in your
business
and so when you have the best hand and
you know it because you've been paying
attention and you know how to play poker
you go all in
everybody here is playing facebook
instagram social media youtube
podcasting like they have the best hand
and they're calling
and you're not goading them into getting
all the money you're just folding
and that's this audience so can you
imagine what i feel is going on outside
this stadium
so this is a call to action for
everybody
to do me one favor and i do think i can
get a lot of you to do it which excites
me
please
right now listen maybe you've laid out
money maybe you're in the middle of a
renovation maybe you're paying for your
kids college mazel tov i know there's
nuances on everybody's life
but if you are in a position where
literally your take-home income this
year is literally the stuff you're going
to go and do things with please
from twenty five percent to ninety
percent if you can go humble
please take that money and hire two
people to make a lot more content for
you about you and your business
and please give the rest of the money
to facebook
and youtube
and instagram
and i fundamentally promise you you will
walk here to this conference next year
and personally thank me emotionally
because your business will change and i
know not one of you has gone all in i
was born in belarus in the former soviet
union
i came to the u.s when i was three we
lived a very humble beginning as you can
imagine the economy wasn't super great
we didn't speak english we had a 100
bucks uh i lived with seven family
members in a studio apartment in queens
um so it was super humble as you and
you know obviously my parents are very
much my heroes uh one because my mom is
the greatest parent of all time and two
because my dad worked his face off and
even though i slept under the same roof
literally every day of my life with my
dad in the first 14 years of my life i
literally never saw him because he left
at 7am or 6am and he came home at 10pm
and he worked seven days a week
how many people here are immigrants or
children of immigrants raise your hands
awesome so
this group that just raised their hands
they know that immigrants in america
have absolutely figured out one of the
core secrets which is
you know work your face off and don't
buy dumb
and so
that's kind of what my family did for
seven or eight years you know we my dad
wasn't making that much money but a
funny thing happens when you buy nothing
but food at the lowest possible price
and uh save save save save and very
quickly only six years after coming to
america with a hundred bucks my dad was
able to buy a small liquor store in new
jersey we moved to new jersey that is
where my entrepreneurial career began
uh when i was six
i had a
five lemonade stand
franchise i
manipulated my friends into standing
behind the lemonade all day and that is
when i became obsessed with attention
and this is really interesting as you
can see up here i day trade attention
culture and build businesses
at six years old
i would spend my summer days literally
walking up and down the streets of new
jersey
sitting down on the curb watching cars
drive by so that i could figure out
which tree or post was better for me to
put a sign that said lemonade a quarter
that is dna that's like somebody singing
that's like somebody throwing a pitch
really like that is just pure dna i
didn't read a seth godin book or go over
to harvard business school to figure out
that attention was the number one asset
the one thing that combines every person
here from the cameramen back there who
are producing to the industry that is in
this room to me to mickey to anybody
else that sneaked in the one thing that
fundamentally connects all of us is
before you tell me how great your
product and services you need my
attention so that i listen i am obsessed
with attention i am obsessed with this
device because it has the attention i am
unemotional if it's ruining the kids and
they don't know how to engage or that
you are sad that people go out to dinner
and don't talk to each other technology
does not care about your feelings
and so i as a human may have some
opinions about parenthood and society
and privacy as a human
but as a businessman i am unemotional
and not romantic all i do is follow
where the attention is and i figure out
how to storytell in there to create the
action that i desire
a lot of your advice is geared to like
college grads yep but i'm old i'm 40.
what would you like what was your voice
advice be for someone who's 40 but
starting out where most of your audience
is starting out when they're 20 or 30.
well it's interesting no joke i don't
know if you saw this i literally posted
a video today to 47 year olds
i do not see that yet so
uh to me everybody's going through
different things you know
i to your point in the last 8 12 to 18
months i found myself producing a lot
more content to youth than i have in the
past which was usually to more 40 year
old business people um
look i think the biggest thing with 40
to 50 is that it's now you've lived life
and you're still young as
and you're like now what right you have
like an entire second life to live
and it's a very interesting time in
people's lives where they have to be
really retrospective of like how
self-aware are they
but honestly i think 40's young man i
really really do and so i would say a
lot of the advice i give to 20 year olds
maps pretty well to 40 year olds which
is you know take some risks you've
tasted some stuff
you know
happiness is the roi
and so you know figure out what makes
you happy is it the pursuit of money or
is it actual money do materials make you
happy if materials make you happy is
that really just insecurity and you need
to have you know a bmw to make yourself
feel good like what's making you tick
but i would say the biggest thing that i
would tell any 40 year old is you've got
50 years to live please get the um
finished or i like eliminate dwelling
because you're just starting
i really believe that by the way this is
not some motivational rah-rah
i just think it's true i just think
you've got 40
adult years to live that's 20 more than
you've lived there's just so much
opportunity
the biggest vulnerability everybody has
here
is they're worried about somebody else's
judgment
the reason there's no moment of clarity
is you don't want to jump
you don't want to jump because you're
worried if you lose what people are
going to say starting with your parents
your friends your contemporaries
my ability to not truly truly care about
other people's opinions
has been the
foundation of my
happiness i respect people's opinions
i just
i just don't care about their judgment
of me
i i've flip-flopped about project
management at vaynermedia like so many
times and i don't worry if somebody here
is like make a decision or like you're
stupid or
or why are we always changing like
go work it grey advertising
how much time do you spend on marco
you said those four things how much time
do you actually spend on it
in a day zero sometimes i assume
in a week how much do you spend it
two hours great now is the most
important part of this meeting
how many hours do you sleep at night
great so i love the way you said it i
have to have seven so if i wanted to say
go to six so that you pick up five
you're gonna say to me gary i have to
have seven right
now let's go somewhere else
i have to know what you're doing the
other 17 hours
i would bet the house
that we can find an hour every day
i guarantee it because you might be
working all 17 hours but you might not
be working on something smarter than
spending an hour a day on the thing that
you're talking about
do you understand yeah that's i mean
look that's the answer
the answer is time
you know people talk about working hard
and working smart the answer is only
both
you have to work hard and smart based on
your ambition
if you want to build a business for
yourself
that is like a one percent life most
people understand what building a
business for yourself is it's very
special
it's very special trying to build a
business for yourself everybody's doing
now
pulling it off
trying to play basketball everybody can
try
being an nba player
trying to be a rapper
or a singer
everybody's doing pulling it off
trying to be a footballer an actress
got it
so you're trying great pulling it off is
hard it takes everything
time and smarts
you need seven i'm glad you said it that
way because this makes this piece of
content more valuable
it's the 17 other hours
i'll give you an example a lot of people
drive to work for 45 minutes if they
took a bus for an hour and 15 minutes
they would save money and get more work
done but do you have the humility to
take the bus versus driving your car
you need to ask yourself tonight why
it's more interesting to dwell and
complain and come up with excuses than
actually be happy
i'll save you time your mom
[Laughter]
so
cool
right
or your dad
or your older brother
or some circumstance
here's my big thing
i'm looking around and even for the
geezers in here you're all living for
another 50 years
minimum
there's people in here right i mean
dude i know i know you're like awesome
right because when you were kids you're
like 60
now
now
right now but you know what's crazy now
it is nuts like how many people here are
under 30.
all of you outside of like devastate by
at scale
almost all of you get to 100 110 easy
that's nuts
you're you're freaking out you turned 30
and you were
living for another 95 years
you're like i don't have my together i'm
like you haven't even started there is
no one path the only path is like do you
know yourself and more importantly that
voice inside your own head
a lot of times people don't understand
that that was put in your head a lot of
people when i'm like don't listen to
anybody but yourself i'll get that dm
they're like yo
i love that my problem is i'm telling
myself i suck and then i have to dm like
yo you didn't like that isn't you that's
your mom or dad that put that in your
head and now you believe it and you
think it's your own voice nobody starts
off thinking they suck here's the
problem
and i'm not trying to be mean i'm trying
to make you happy and win
most of the people listening right now
don't have the talent
i know the truth and that's okay and
that is okay okay and by the way some of
the cats in this room probably when you
guys were 7 8 9 10 11 might have thought
you wanted to be the artist yeah but you
might have been a singer you can't see
this crap
and what i would say is kudos to you to
be like yeah look that you understood
that that what you are gonna be
that's it you know what i love i love
perspective
if you're listening to this right now it
means you have the ability to listen to
this right now
which means you live in america it means
that you have some sort of device that
allows you to listen to this
i just don't think people understand how
lucky they have it no matter how they
think they have it dudes that were
trying to kill it didn't use words like
empathy and gratitude seven years ago
like seeing like sleeved up like rad
dudes roll up to me like yo kindness dog
i'm like
it's just so and honestly i genuinely
believe my great legacy potentially
may be that i made emotionally
intelligent
soft skills alpha you know you'll never
believe this this is super interesting
to me
the fact that pink was a boy's color
and blue was a girl's color back in the
day
is kind of how i think about gratitude
empathy kindness i'm like i'm gonna
trick these young dogs
into like thinking this is cool and then
one day in 50 years people can be like
the alpha male traits are like gratitude
and kindness and if i could pull that
off then it's like
my friends this is a remarkably special
time and i'm completely convinced the
far majority and i mean 99 of this room
is going to regret it i'm completely
convinced about it it's not fun for me
to say that but it's very obvious to me
that humans take for granted and are
really bad at perspective and timing the
reason i push patience how many people
here are under 30. raise your hands
stand up if you're under 30. let's first
of all clap it up for all the youngsters
in the room
keep standing
you're young you're not tired yet
if you're standing right now you really
have to like let's get into perspective
and actual understanding if you're
standing right now with the way that
modern medicine is actually evolving
there is a very high percentage
that you're going to live
three more lives that you've already
lived if not five
like do you understand why i struggle
when people give up on
a year or two in or are upset that they
haven't gotten there yet three years in
when you faces are about to live four
more lives
i'm being serious like you're literally
gonna live four more lives five more
like from the day you were born that you
cannot remember
to write this second you're about to do
that three to four more times
you can sit literally
literally
your biggest advantage is timing for all
the great
things that i have in my life i would
literally give it up
all of it all of it just to be 25 i
would give up for 17 years i'd give up
everything i have because that's how
valuable time is
and the far majority of this room has
time
time as their asset
and every day the number one asset they
have time they give away by being
impatient mainly on the back of
listening to society or their parents
that they have to have their figured out
at this age the fact that people
actually think at 18
22 or 30 you have to have your figured
out is ridiculous let me promise you all
those parents and uncles and
grandparents that push down your throat
that you have to figure it out by now
they still haven't figured it out
i mean it
so this
nonsense that you have to have it
figured out at 18 22 30. how many people
freaked out at 30 how many people are 30
right now
that's crazy right
like people lose their at 30.
like meanwhile they're a
kid
and so i'm unbelievably
um aware lately that one of the you know
people always like why do you when i
talk about my parents and not coming
from anything but the more that i live
i'm like
the reason i really win
is because i understand time
and listen i know i can get hit by a bus
or get terminally ill i get it here's
the problem that's far more unlikely for
the majority of us
the math works in your favor and we are
stunningly not patient
patience has been the foundation of my
patience adversity these are the
foundations of my success the other
thing i'm a very big believer in is
getting people to not feel like it's a
scarlet letter if they lose
something nobody talks about at all is
your scenario you jump
it fails
you reset and go back
and get a job in the craft that you had
because of your resume
and you restart in four years from now
we have we so
america's pretty good at looking at
losses in a positive way compared to
other parts of the world where it's like
a true scarlet letter death forever
but still even here
you know people don't know when to go
back
from their jump
because they don't want the loss on the
resume
they made the big to-do that they're
good you're gonna do it
now it doesn't work and what they do is
they triple down into debt
to look good in front of people and what
if it did and you never jumped to find
out oh you're preaching that i want
you've already done that i'm actually
talking about the next part which is
having the options
to know that the game is super long and
that if the business when you go from
ice cold when you go from never having a
business to having a business that's
like literally asking me i'm asking you
to right now qualify for wimbledon in
tennis
it's a lot harder than people think
you're grown you two are grown
i'm not trying to suppress by the way
i'm talking about the practicality of
like options
i love that we live in a world i'm
trying to get people to like really
understand how to win this
so much of my success is completely
predicated on not worrying about all my
losses which means at times you know my
great losses are the things i passed on
maybe i should have done shark tank
maybe
maybe
maybe not
i don't think i should have done it
not this late in i think i'll do my own
thing like you know like but i could but
[ __ ] i mean there's a lot of i mean i
didn't invest in uber
when i could have made 400 million
i mean that's a loss a lot of people
that follow you or a lot of business
people they started the freelancers in
any field whether it's writer filmmaker
whatever they start as a freelancer
usually with a part-time full-time job
then at what point if the business going
okay or cash should they
either stay a freelancer or become a
freelancer with a micro freelancing team
or get full timers and open businesses
the answer is depending on your
situation
if you're 21 and you have no expenses
and you're living at home you have to go
high risk as soon as you see any blood
in the water you go if i'm 21 and i'm at
home
and i have no expenses
and
and i'm making 47 000 euros pounds
dollars doing something i don't love but
i want to be a film person and the first
person pays me 1500
or a dollar forever and it works and it
went well and she the boss of this candy
store says i'm gonna tell my friends
about you
i may jump right away
i don't have any concerns if i'm 42
years old and i have three kids and a
mortgage and i'm a hundred thousand
dollars in debt because i went to
college in america and it didn't get me
a good job and i'm an accountant and i
make 137 000 a year which basically pays
for my overhead roughly because i bought
a house bigger than i needed i bought a
car bigger than i needed this cliche
american
and somebody pays me 1500 and they're
like i'm gonna tell my friends i'm gonna
give up netflix and my video games and
my weekends to eventually get that to 60
or 70 or 80 or 90 000 a year before i
say okay now i'm at 90 137 if i actually
went all in i can close the gap on that
57 000. now i'm gonna make the jump
because i have three kids a mortgage in
debt
every piece of my advice is
circumstantial
what makes me vulnerable in producing
pieces of content on the internet is it
lacks context for every individual
the reason i produce so much content is
the reason a piece of content may hit
somebody different this time next time
is because even the same person's life
changes
yeah true yesterday aaron is 25 and
single and living at home tomorrow he
meets sheila falls in love
and
you know
a million things can happen sheila could
be making a million dollars a year a
different life sheila could be making no
money but he loves her so much and she
wants to buy handbags every day and now
he has a bigger you know financial
problem sheila wants to be his partner
she like he wants to buy handbags it's
not cliche it's life it's contextual and
that's why the answer to your question
is a million things but you jump
when you can afford to drown
you jump when you can afford to drown
what i mean by that is when you jump
into the pool
you have to know that you've never swam
before and you might drown
and you have to be able to do that when
you can
and at 21 living at home you can yeah
because you can go back and get a job
you have no overhead
right but at 43 with three kids
you might not want to yeah and by the
way or you might you might have such a
supportive spouse sheila aaron's the
stay home dad sheila's making the 147.
sheila talks to aaron says aaron i'm
going to die if i don't jump i'm 43 and
if i don't jump now i'm going to be 62
and regret it my whole life so i'm going
to jump
and if i fail and the economy collapses
and i can't get a job we may have to
sell this home we may have to move in
with our parents in florida but i have
to do that and take the loss in front of
everybody's eyes that we're losers and
we
because i know myself and i know if i
don't jump now
i'm going to be miserable for 40 years
that i was an accountant for my whole
life in 1996 my dad had a liquor store
in new jersey that's as traditional as
you get yeah that was 22 years ago
and
and i put my dad's store on online and i
did email marketing and i did google and
i did content and then a couple months
after youtube came out i started a
youtube show in 2006 which is now 12
years ago
i i i have no respect
or
normally i deploy a lot of empathy i i
struggle deploying empathy i struggle
deploying compassion if you were a
business operator in
yeah heading in but i'm recording this
in october 2019 which is the majority of
people are gonna listen to this and you
and your excuses while i'm a pub or i
make tomato juice or i have three
restaurants like i digital is oxygen
it's it's it's the real world
feels secondary yeah like to not be a
communicator content producer
um part of the conversation like it's
it's now it's gone from cute and naive
to grossly negligent yeah
and
i just think it's unacceptable
to be a business in 2019 in the same way
that it would be to pay people not
minimum wage like i literally believe
it's grossly unacceptable like to me
it's like it's like to to quantify
digital versus traditional just
marketing like really you think sending
direct mail print
is a better thing to do than advertising
on instagram as a restaurant like like
really like really sit down with me
you're telling me right now that it's a
better deal to spend all that money
making a flyer and sending it direct
mail
or running a radio ad
or buying a small little ad in a
newspaper like this is what you're
telling me it is 2019. i felt bad in
2002. it was early the internet was new
i had compassion it was cute in 2007 it
was like
it was kind of like
like hey
annoying kind of like
but still kind of in 2012 is like you're
not smart in 2019 like
you deserve to die i love when people
like
gary v like the comments are just so fun
garyvee like you suck bro you repeat the
same
i'm like because it's right
face
the reason i keep repeating it the
reason i believe in it is because i know
for so many of you even though you've
seen it 87 times
this moment in real life at this time
might be the time it happens that's how
it actually works
this is a game of perspective either you
understand what's happening or not do
you know how many people have defaulted
into thinking this is a terrible time my
friends this is the greatest time to be
a human being in the history of earth
i mean i don't know what else to tell
you this is like math this is not my
opinion this is what's going on with
genocide and health life expense like
this is the best
like for all the
we have with racism and sexism and a lot
of terror we got plenty
meanwhile
they had the black plague
meanwhile they had world war
ii
meanwhile they had real
and we sit around and complain about the
dumbest in the world
people complain about like getting the
wrong milk in their coffee from a
barista
or that you're what this is my your
wi-fi is a little slower than normal
like you're upset
you can feel the speed it's a little
lower or
or my or
you got a few less likes than you're
usually getting on a po like the stuff
that we actually spend time on is
fascinating
to me
it is a complete and utter lack of
perspective i was a super
entrepreneurial kid you know it's very
rare for somebody growing up in the 80s
who's an immigrant to not be blindly
bought into education as the way out
miraculously i have such a great mother
who saw
a four or five six i mean young five six
seven eight year old kid basically spend
all his time on business
lemonade you know i was a four season
executive you know in the fall i'm
raking leaves in the winter i'm
shoveling snow and singing christmas
carols at your door i mean i literally i
don't talk about that a lot i literally
rang people's doors and be like do you
want us will you pay us a dollar to sing
jingle bells me and my crew i mean it
was ludicrous and you're jewish right
and i'm jewish i mean it was like talk
about how i'm entrepreneur first uh
you know in the spring it was like we
did a i remember we did a miniature golf
course we did flea mar mini flea markets
it was a garage sale in the summer it
was hardcore washing cars and lemonade
i was so passionate and then very
quickly for a lot of people watching
they'll probably remember this in the
late 80s early 90s the baseball card
phenomenon in america happened and i was
at the forefront not only was i
collecting but as a 12 year old i'm in
in hotels in malls in convention centers
set up as a dealer with other 30 40 50
year old men
and really cut my teeth there and then
my 14th birthday came and i for whatever
reason i guess that's grown up in russia
land my dad at this point in parallel
was also an entrepreneur more a more
significant one saved up all his money
as a stock boy and then manager of a
liquor store which is the job he got in
america and bought
a liquor store and
dragged me into that liquor store in
springfield new jersey when i was 14 and
so from eighth grade on
i worked one of the things i saw a lot
in my comments because i read them all
was well i have no money i'm like
i lived my whole life with no money but
i figured it out i would just buy
i would buy garage sale
and it just got me going going i love it
it's like a hobby of mine to go garage
start doing that with clothes i did i
used to do that with clothes dude you
met guys
especially like a stylish kid like you
like if you have flavor if you're
listening right now and you don't have
money but you're cool or you got flavor
you got swag you got style
if you just spend your life in goodwill
and in thrift stores yeah and buy that
you think is fresh
and then wear it and take a selfie and
put it on ebay for three times the price
or like i see every day the amount of
people that buy three dollar t-shirts
and sell them for 35 bucks on ebay and
etsy and facebook marketplace is
enormous there's no excuse in america to
say you have no money even if you're in
the deepest poorest places because if
you can literally get a dollar you can
buy your first t-shirt at goodwill and
get it up for 15 bucks on facebook
because you know what's funny
what's funny is everybody's got a
smartphone
like you go into the poorest places in
america and everybody's got a smartphone
which means you have the internet i mean
listen the homeless you've got people
all over on home homeless smartphones i
get emails every day i'm homeless i
watch you on youtube people like gary i
hit up i dm'd all the influencers like
you told me nobody responded i'm like
how many they're like 130 i'm like good
there's about nine million more
and you just say will you help me
no because that's not the way to
position it right because most people
won't answer that because somebody who's
got an audience that's all they see
right i would say how can i help you
right
that was my question you see where i'm
going yeah like
like yo with you
like how can i help you but then like if
you don't have any leverage yes you do
you have your time
you never know drock didn't have any
leverage
drock asked me four times and then
finally i said yeah fine make me a video
not even that mindset and then this all
happened because of it that's real
that's real that's the story
that's the story he asked me four times
i want to make a video for you he was a
video guy i wasn't making content like
that then
and but it was in my mind
and by the fourth time i was like you
know what
okay
make me a free video show me
here we are
now he's the
the word that people use like people
literally say literally a verb
literally people are like that my
drock's name is rick you know doc's a
name
you know what i mean
it's real and and you know what i said
this at the time that director said
you're gonna impact people like do you
know how awesome it is for people that
love to do it to do it you know many
people wanted to make documentaries
their whole lives yet only 74 people a
year get to do them and now 74 000
people you don't get to do it
all it takes is one person so with real
estate
following this gentleman pretty much
personal branding yes
yes
okay um
the question is since we're so small how
soon does that get played out people are
like do one listen to him
well if you talk
my big thing is just talk about your
singular truth and your uniqueness
people may follow you just for your
ranching tips
or because your tire on your truck you
need to change and you videoed it i mean
people think people are like i'm not
interesting and i'm like people are
interesting
if you weren't interesting we wouldn't
have traffic
rubbernecking is completely based on
you know what a yenta is
it's not necessarily a good you know
it's more of an israeli word necessarily
than but like people are interested in
other people
so you don't have a whole lot to say
about like expertise like somebody who's
been in the business for 27 years that's
her advantage right but for now your
advantage is the documentation of trying
to make it your side hustle
like if you live streamed
you're enti
somebody in here is gonna live stream an
entire open house where nobody shows up
right
and right right and then one of those at
the right time is going to go viral as
somebody who's persevering through
adversity
chewbacca mom happens a lot
you just have to put yourself in a
position
somebody decided to post a photo of an
egg
you understand
you understand
like everybody's saying no
you are all saying no for the audience
i never say no
if i would have said no for you i
wouldn't have made a cartoon photo post
and realized you guys want cartoon photo
post for me too
those comic posts i started posting in
january are outperforming my standard
content
so what do you do you just post all
sorts of
shave your beard good content
i mean it i mean it
like and you live in a part of the world
that new yorkers don't get like there's
you just never know but everybody says
no and i always say yes
that is literally the binary difference
and i'm willing to deal with when it's a
no because i don't care about the
judgment
you like reading the comments
love you do it on every video every post
all day
how do you how do you deal with the
negativity someone's talking about
biting your nails empathetic
empathy
somebody just watched 49 seconds of me
spitting
some pontification on instagram
and they've decided to make a judgment
on me
and i respect that i put myself out
there
they don't know everything about me
so when they
drag me down be like this guy's
fully
i'm like that makes sense
they saw me in explore feature they're
like who's this face they watch it they
don't like it
and they decide i'm
and they're not in a good place so they
have to drag down i deploy empathy first
sucks to be i would never do that as a
happy person to anybody else so hey i'm
already feel bad yeah and b who the [ __ ]
am i they only got 49 seconds and in 49
seconds at a time i could suck
in perpetuity
you know like at 49 seconds at a time
i could be all-time terrible especially
me that gets hot and competitive and
like
you know like this is how i am when the
lights come on so
i deal with the negativity with empathy
to the person that's leaving the comment
a for the fact that i feel bad because
they're in a bad place that they decided
to put more hate into the system and b
like they shouldn't do seven hours of
research of my career or who i am as a
human being
i would be upset if you thought i was
because you've had enough interactions
at this point to have a read yeah so you
talk patience too right that people
should be patient in in the pursuit of
their goals at what point does patient
just become delusion a lot of times
oh so
what are the hacks or the tips that you
for them to be self-aware to know when
to just
when does patience just run out if
you've been doing the same thing for
seven years and nothing good has
happened you're delusional let's start
there that's a test i believe in that if
there's been no progress in your rap
career or in your art or your video blog
and you've been doing it every day for
seven years as hard as you can and
nothing has happened the market has
spoken that's one way now is that four
years is that two years do people jump
off like you need to see some level of
progress
to keep you
having blood in the water to get you
going
but sometimes there is a breakthrough
because if the machine is in between you
and the market well then you got to be
discovered but the reason now i think
it's more pure is because soundcloud and
spotify and youtube and shopify and
amazon now you get the feedback loop so
fast and it isn't the arbitrary
subjective call the reason it took some
of the greatest stars of all time 11
years to break through is because other
people had say people didn't see gaga's
talent they thought she was weird
somebody thought she wasn't weird she
breaks out like lady gaga today she goes
on youtube and spotify direct and the
market speaks quicker people are more
famous quicker now if they have the
talent because nobody's in the middle
this is why i talk in general terms on
content of course because i don't have
the context but if somebody sat here and
i listened for 40 minutes i would tell
them if they're delusional or just
impatient and most people are impatient
and delusional evan thank you so much
for having a couple seconds and being
able to tell the believe nation a little
bit about empathy wines it means a lot
to me that you would take this valuable
real estate and and time on your channel
to give me some love means a lot it's
just good karma points and so you're
just you're awesome thank you believe
nation uh if you're into wine at all go
to empathywines.com
my whole career's work was poured into
producing a wine that rivaled 40 to 60
dollar wine for 20 bucks a bottle uh i'm
just super excited about this
subscription-based wine business you can
order three six or 12 bottles in
subscription forum rose white red um if
you if you search on instagram or
twitter you will be blown away people
are literally like i don't even like
garyvee but the line's good
super proud of the effort thanks evan
for the time uh wishing you guys all
happy and healthy if you want to see the
last one-on-one i did with gary
vaynerchuk check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i'm talking about something that
the world thinks is a contradiction i
don't understand why anybody
should ever verbally dress down
an employee